hello everyone and a special shout out
to all of you naval aviators
professional beach volleyball players
welcome back to rotten tomatoes is wrong
the week of mark continues because this
is a bonus episode that look we told
jacqueline coley we're going to do this
episode so we're not we're not trying to
cut anybody out of anything she's just
still enjoying a well-deserved
much-needed break from all of this movie
madness she gears up for award season
next year and she's at film festivals
probably right now we get to talk about
a beloved classic today yeah we had
return of the jedi yesterday and that's
my favorite movie of all time
in a close
race
for this one's probably in my top 10 at
least my top 10 most seen movies of all
time and that would of course be the
1986
classic top
gun tom cruise val kilmer kelly mcgillis
anthony edwards for a little bit meg
ryan what a classic
film featuring a lot of f-14s a ton of
kenny loggins and a bunch of great
action and romance and heartache and
victory and all that good stuff that you
love in just a it balls out at adventure
action-packed flick directed by tony
scott's we're talking about that and you
can hear the excitement in my voice
but the tomato meter just sometimes it
likes to rain on parades and that's
what's happening right now 57
rotten it's close to fresh fresh would
be 60 it's fresh adjacent but it is a
rotten film according to the tomato
meter the good news is it's 83 on the
audience score so there's some measure
of redemption there i think we're gonna
get a little more today because we're
all excited about the new film top gun
maverick finally in theaters later on
this month and this is a movie that
we've really been waiting for since we
saw the first one but more particularly
the last couple years it's had a lot of
release dates and then due to the nature
of the world it's moved off of those and
now we finally get to see it now it's
gory memorial day weekend speaking of
glory speaking of well these guys
probably enjoy their weekends too our
guests today are
the action guys one half of the action
guys is also an incredible musician and
you know him from his podcast exploits
as well as being one of the great movie
trivia showdown minds i've ever
witnessed in my time
ben bateman is here hello sir thank you
for having me mr ellis this episode is a
special one my friend i mean let's be
honest we ripped off the top gun logo
for our logo there's mo no more fitting
place to be for the action guys than
talking about top gun
and uh i am i'm thrilled to be here 80s
had a lot of great logos and top gun is
right up there with the best of the
bunch uh speaking of the best you wanted
the best you got the best you can't have
mad without goose you can't have goose
without mav and so he's the other half
of the action guys you know him from his
podcast ex-boys he's a very talented
actor with a couple films in the can
currently he also is the best announcer
in the history of the movie trivia
schmodown andrew guy look at this we're
we're back buddy and you have it what's
up man you have a very fervent love for
top gun that is evident if you're
watching us right now yeah it's one of
one of those things top gun is a movie
that i it took me a long time to love i
think as much as i do now i love tom
cruise i love tony scott i absolutely
adore val kilmer so everything about
this movie it on paper it seemed like it
should be my favorite movie of all time
i think maybe just because it came out
before i was born and it took me a few
years to to really fall in love with it
my love now for top gun is so full
throttle i won't do that anymore i
promise i'll be the last one
i don't mind the puns i just mind the
the pointing out right off the bat that
oh well this was before i was born so we
get it you're still in your prime
congratulations i'm 23 years old ellis
but i'm still really excited about
living in hollywood and god he looks
good so i also want to bring in producie
lucy just right now because lucy this is
a movie that you know i was very excited
to talk about this movie really since
the inception of our show rotten
tomatoes is wrong and finding out that
this is a movie that's rotten on the
tomato meter do you have a stronghold
you don't have to give it away now but
do you have a strong opinion one way or
the other on top gun or is it just a
dude movie which is why we have dudes
talking about it no this is this is a
movie for all peoples all people's
everywhere throughout all time this
movie transcends space and time
it sounds like your household enjoys the
film as well everything it does they're
very late
lucy's mansion getting very very excited
about it so top gun if you don't know
we're gonna spoil the movie and there's
a part in the middle that i still get
yelled at by younger fans saying how
could you ruin that part of the movie
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it here
today top gun is the story of lieutenant
pete mitchell call sign maverick his
best bud goose and a whole bunch of
other fighter pilots who go to top
gun because they're the best of the best
they're training to be the ultimate
naval aviators and along
side of them is going to be val kilmer
you get rick rosavik you get whip hub
wig get very tough i remember most of
the names and then you have tom skerritt
michael ironside as their instructors
and of course charlie is the call sign
of the civilian but she's like the
civilian gets to look at all the
classified stuff played by kelly
mcgillis they love they lose and they
end up winning it all at the end of the
day except not everybody's along for the
entire ride hence the dog tag throw that
still gets me emotional to this very day
so the question is this gentlemen
starting with you andrew
simply put is rotten tomatoes wrong
about top gun with that 57
so rotten tomatoes is
150 wrong on this i mean 57
is insulting
that means that over half the people
that went and saw this movie they were
on the fence about whether they liked it
or not with it leaning towards maybe
that one person being like yeah i guess
it was okay like 57 is an insulting
number for a lot of really bad films out
there to put top gun there is just it's
it's shocking like uh when i went and
saw the numbers i couldn't believe it
this movie is at least at the very least
a 78 probably pushing to 84 in my
opinion okay going from 78 to 84.
ironically those are the years that
david lee roth was in van halen uh let's
go to ben bateman you
i believe feel the same way as andrew
but i want to put words in your mouth
ben this is your platform and a safe
space to express yourself and
particularly your feelings about top gun
is rotten tomatoes wrong it is
absolutely wrong i think top gun exists
as kind of a cartoon time capsule of
what an 80s action movie is supposed to
look like and ironically i think tony
scott ended up taking a lot of the
feeling and the vibe where it's so so
shiny and so polished it's almost too
much but it's not it's like the sweetest
candy that you can just stomach eating
that's like what his career ended up
being and i think this is the earliest
version of that so for me the more times
i watch it the more years that pass the
more times i listen to that beautiful
lover boy track on the soundtrack uh the
more i'm just convinced that this movie
is like the pinnacle of 80s action movie
it's different than predator it's a
totally different vibe but they both
sort of fit you know in the crown that
crown space i put this close to 90.
personally all right so to uh to
paraphrase ben bateman this movie is
heaven in your eyes and it really is for
all of us because we are going to be
talking about that exquisite soundtrack
the the amazing direction by tony scott
this is biggest movie ever the and tony
scott has done he's he's the action guy
as far as i'm concerned y'all are doing
a great job carrying his torch but tony
scott is the action guy because every
one of his action movies just is a
thrill ride nonstop this in my humble
opinion is the best of the bunch so
we're going to talk about all of these
things we're going to maybe do some
quotes we might do a little bit of
singing there's going to be a lot of fun
here as we celebrate top gun in
anticipation of top gun maverick but
before we think about the future we're
going to take a look back to the past
with our dear friend tim ryan our expert
review curation manager here at rotten
tomatoes for his segment that's going to
tell us what the critics were saying at
the time in 1986 of top gun's release
two minutes with time
[Music]
tell us what the critics were saying
[Music]
plenty of movies emphasize style over
substance and that's not necessarily a
bad thing and even the biggest fans
would probably admit the top gun could
be described that way but if it's a
question of whether top gun is a case of
style carrying the day or substance
bringing the whole thing down to earth
reviewers were largely split
by and large the critics felt that while
the aerial sequences were undeniably
exhilarating character development was
in decidedly short supply
top gun is rotten at 57 on the tomato
meter with 63 reviews but it does have
an 83 audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a rotten review
roger ebert of the chicago sun times
wrote the dogfights are absolutely the
best since clint eastwood's electrifying
aerial scenes in firefox but look out
for the scenes where people talk to one
another
however in a fresh review harper barnes
of the st louis post dispatch wrote if
you like airplane movies top gun is
about 1 3 of a dazzler and the rest is
at least watchable the rotten tomatoes
critic's consensus reads though it
features some of the most memorable and
electrifying aerial footage shot with an
expert eye for action top gun offers too
little for non-adolescent viewers to
chew on when its characters aren't in
the air
so that's top gun let's kick it back to
mark who feels the need
the need for podcasting back to you
you're right i do tim and and now now
you really got me if i was just like mav
at the end of top gun sitting on the
tarmac waiting to possibly have to take
off and get into the dog fight now i'm
in there i'm fired up after these these
critical barbs that were lobbed against
top gun at the time you can never tell
how a movie is going to have staying
power decades and decades upon it's it's
released thereafter but top gun i feel
like it's one of those movies do the
boys agree does lucy agree do you agree
out there in the world we're gonna get
into all that right now with movie talk
[Music]
all right right out of the gate before
we even get into your favorite
characters your favorite scenes have ben
bateman and andrew guy ever teamed up on
a beach to play volleyball together
[Applause]
ben i'll let you take this one yeah
that's a question i'm gonna
i'm gonna swing back around and answer
that one later in the show ellis um
yeah there you go
made a couple of trips out to the court
i love playing beach volleyball i prefer
beach volleyball two on two beach
volleyball is very tough to pull off but
if it's like a team if you have like the
six on each side then i feel like i'm in
my comfort zone but two on two that puts
a lot of pressure on each individual and
i am not a pilot of an f-14 i don't
think i'd be able to handle it yeah i
mean six on six a lot of baby oil on the
court there the two on two you're able
to just take care of each other take
care of the court it's it's a lot more
fun that way
it really is an enjoyable experience
watching this movie start to finish and
i i love the way that this movie it
kicks off with a bang because we get to
see
some aerial high-flying acrobatics with
the plane literally going inverted
within the first five minutes of this
movie and then that's when we find out
that despite the apprehension of some of
the brass goose and maverick because
cougar washed out are going to be sent
to miramar california just north of san
diego to go to top gun and from there
our adventure ensues so ben baben i'll
put the question to you first if you
have to pick just one scene in all of
top guns and it can be spoiler heavy it
could be whatever scene you feel like
beginning middle or end what is your
favorite top gun part it is such a tough
question to answer mr ellis i i feel
like
i'm split between two because there's
there's the good stuff in top gun which
is like the fist pump action stuff and
then there's also the stuff that's so
insanely over the top like the campiest
absurd stuff so i'm gonna go with one of
the good ones i'll swing back around the
other one maybe in another segment i
think i gotta go
with you never close your eyes the song
in the bar um i think there's just
something about it that's just so
ridiculous over the top
uh
memorable like you feel the camaraderie
it's just great tom cruise is a bad
singer he's horrible it's shockingly bad
but i think that's the point right i
think it's the same thing that happens
when they when they haven't do it in
jerry maguire years later they're like
you have to sing badly that's the point
here and i think he does and it's so
charming um i don't know there's like
almost no more obnoxious arrogant
character in the history of cinema than
pete mitchell he he kind of just defines
that and the arrogance to pull that move
in a bar with all the support it i don't
know and then with goose he stops him
it's just so good i'll never get over
that scene it's i think it's my favorite
movie excuse me miss hey hey don't worry
i'll take care of this
you never close your eyes anymore when i
kiss
your lips
there's no tenderness like before in
your fingertips
[Music]
the support is what really wins me over
in that scene andrew is because like we
know that mav and goose have done this
trick in the bar when he's trying to
impress uh in this case kelly mcgillis
he doesn't realize at the time that
she's on a date with an older guy um and
the whole
team the whole all the naval who are in
insane competition trying to get their
name on the wall to be the best of the
best pilots they're all singing along
but you don't see iceman singing and
that's the difference i think between
the arrogance of iceman versus maverick
maverick is not only arrogant in his own
abilities he thinks he's a uniter he
thinks he can get everybody involved on
the same team iceman
cool calculated calm he knows he's the
best but he's not going to try to get
anybody else up to his level yeah he's
not going to stoop down to the level of
singing this absurd song in a bar he's
already people come to iceman he just
sits back with his vodkas on on the
rocks i think is what everyone was
drinking in that scene was just like
vodka straight on the rocks yeah these
are the most precision aviators in the
world they just drink straight vodka
that's definitely they're like having
the conversation between goose and
maverick and iceman and they're just
like taking a shot every 10 seconds it's
pretty impressive you know i do know
that oh sorry i was just saying you know
that iceman's sitting there looking at
maverick the whole time and he's like
i'd never do it because i'm too cool but
you know that in his mind he's like god
i wish i could be that cool i wish i
could do it but i got my brand he's got
his i can't do that thing that he's
doing and that's a pivotal scene because
we see the matchup the one-on-one
between maverick and iceman we see the
one-on-one of rios which is the pilot
who is sitting right behind the pilot
it's it's like your backup it's right
there that does all the uh more
technical stuff and is probably worried
about uh your your how much gas you have
left i've never phoned a jet if in case
you all can't tell and you have goose
versus slider there and there they
square off for a little bit so that
really sets the table as far as the game
goes as far as who is going to be on top
who's going to come out of this with the
real top gun attitude andrew guy
if i take you out of that bar and i put
you in any other scene in this movie
what's your favorite it's the next scene
it's the morning after when they're
there on the base and charlie shows up
and she gets introduced and maverick
like slinks down in his chair and puts
on the shades he like doesn't want to be
seen he doesn't want to be acknowledged
but then of course because he is
maverick because he has the biggest ego
in the room the moment that one thing is
said that is incorrect in his mind his
whole uh monologue about the mig and
flying next to it going upside down and
watching it do an inverted dive and all
that stuff is is so good because there
is so much
like tension between him and mcgillis
him and charlie there but she's like
intrigued by what's happening i just
think it's it's one of the best scenes
in the movie when you talk about how
it's acted and the way it kind of makes
you feel uncomfortable but you're also
like
man he he really is an awesome pilot
like he knows more than she knows and
she has the clearance for everything i
just i just love that scene because it
it like it's the power dynamic
continuing from the night before at the
bar
excuse me lieutenant
is there something wrong yes ma'am the
data in the mig is inaccurate
how's that lieutenant
well i just happened to see a mig-28
sorry
we happen to see a mig-28 do a 4g
negative dive
where did you see this
that's classified it's what
it's classified
i could tell you but then i'd have to
kill you lieutenant i have top secret
clearance
the pentagon sees to it that i know more
than you
oh ma'am it doesn't seem so in this case
now does it yeah map knows everything
about about flying a plane he maybe have
a little catch-up to do as far as the
dating and relationship advice goes
because it's such a great juxtaposition
of seeing him hit on her with absolutely
no luck at the bar the night before and
then she ends up being the instructor
the next day and the look that goose
gives to because he recognizes her from
the bar then he's looking over at mav
and he goose is having a great time in
that morning meeting even though like
you all pointed out every one of those
pilots must be insanely hungover and
then oh it's casual you know i'm
hungover i can go to dunkin donuts these
guys are hungover and they're flying
jets which is sort of a shocking moment
here in the history of rt is wrong that
neither one of y'all picked an actual
aerial combat scene i love the training
hops that they take but that's where
this movie it does get a little tough to
rewatch time and time again simply
because i know what's coming and so i
hate seeing
the
the training sequence where goose ends
up meeting his demise the one before
that where it is set to the
instrumentation of cheap tricks mighty
wings which is a very underrated song on
that soundtrack it might be the best
song in the whole soundtrack i love that
because that's when we get to see how
good everybody is but also
how incredible the instructors are how
great michael ironside's gesture is and
how great tom skerritt close personal
friend of mine viper is and so getting
to getting to see all of those elements
in play one of my favorites and then we
build up to this incredible climax where
goose dies and mav couldn't save him and
mavis is beating himself up and we get a
pep talk from viper at viper's house
that's another one and ben this might go
more towards your like favorite campy
scenes in the movie i love love love the
scene where mav goes and we don't know
why he's going to viper's house maybe he
wants to quit maybe he he just wants a
pep talk from his coach
but he's greeted at the door by viper's
wife and viper's wife
calls him maverick and i'm like this is
hysterical that these these call signs
extend to immediate family members like
i bet viper's wife has not called him by
his actual name in 30 years i bet he
makes his family members refer to him as
viper and refer to all of his students
as their call signs
well hi maverick come on in
how are you doing good
are you sure you're feeling okay
great jamie come on can i get you a
drink or
no thank you
okay well why don't you just uh thank
you very much make yourself comfortable
because mike will be right down okay
great thank you ben am i seeing this am
i looking too deep into this no i think
you're dead right i know i know that the
story goes that you know kilmer was
referred to as iceman in every airport
for 36 years by every pilot that he ever
met i mean like these these are
nicknames that went beyond the movie and
i think we could all be so lucky i mean
i you know you mentioned the movie
trivia mode on ls i if someday i'm
walking through the airport in 20 years
and some random person calls me boss i
mean i'll know i did something right and
that's only you know just just an ounce
just an ounce of what these men got to
experience in the film so i i don't
think you're wrong about that at all
yeah choose your nicknames wisely
because i guarantee you in 20 years i'll
be walking through an airport and a
bunch of people are going to shout baby
carrots at me and probably
throw a couple vegetables my way um
andrew do you have a uh an alternative
scene it sort of harkens to what ben was
talking about where it's like
maybe it could be red that it is over
the top but you enjoy it nonetheless uh
i mean
yeah i mean it's it's the it's the beach
volleyball scene right like it's
incredible it's absolutely incredible
and it goes like it's the greatest back
to back to back songs it's playing with
the boys and then it goes to take my
breath away and then you get sitting on
the dock of the bay and then it goes
back to take my breath away uh it
doesn't really get much better than that
like five to ten minutes of film
watching and then the fact that tony
scott referred to it he's like i've got
a bunch of hot dudes i want to shoot a
soft porn for this one scene to show him
off
it's just incredible because no matter
what when you go and you watch that
scene no matter how much you like this
movie or dislike this movie you have to
stop and you have to watch that's that's
all there is to it you do we watch this
movie um this was one of those college
movies that every group of college folk
have their go-to movies and for a lot
and for us too it was like dazed and
confused and the big lebowski and
tombstone was a big one but top gun made
it into the rotation especially freshman
year because we actually had a sand
volleyball pit right outside of our dorm
and so there were a lot of attempts to
be
slider and ice and goose and mav and
according to the the mythology tony
scott wanted to do that scene and they
just trucked in a bunch of sand they
dumped it they built a volleyball court
and they knocked that scene out in one
day the thing that bums me out is that
apparently like when the the far away
shots the wide shots when they're
actually you know playing decent
volleyball those are stunt doubles those
are professional players that look like
our four lads that we're rooting for or
against in this movie but nothing beats
the scene
during this volleyball sequence ben
where we get to see rick rosavik just go
full flexes sliders for no reason in
particular he just loves posing in baby
oil it's the best my question to you mr
ellis is uh when you did your volleyball
sequences did you also wear jeans like
tom cruise because it is the most
uncomfortable i think about what must
have been going on
covered in sweat in a t-shirt with a
leather jacket and sand and
ass-type jeans after playing volleyball
i was like it like makes me
uncomfortable to think about walking
into someone's home in that state which
of course is the point of course but
like every time i watch them just like
this what who wears jeans and especially
those jeans the better question and to
answer yours no i never played in jeans
but i did have a pair of sweatpants that
i cut off mid-shin and we refer to them
as sweat chants a mix between shorts and
pants because i wanted to look like
slider and at least my sweatpants did
the rest of me not so much andrew you
ever been on a date where you came right
from an athletic competition and you
still have you know sand in all of those
parts downstairs
i i think more about like when i used to
go to my barber after the gym and and
that he didn't ever tell me to stop
coming i've been going to him like six
years and finally a couple years ago i
was like this poor guy he's never said a
thing i come in there my hair is like
wet from from being at the gym and uh
that's probably the closest it's come
dates i usually try to uh you know
shower beforehand instead of showing up
at their house and then being like oh
you're going to finish cooking dinner
i'm just gonna go shower in your
bathroom now by the way nice to be at
your house for the very first time
thanks for having me over
it's such a weird thing that they throw
in there but i guess to ben's point
you're watching it you're like oh he
just came straight from the volleyball
court we we have to acknowledge this in
the film it has to be put in the script
that he wants to shower i think that's i
think that's part of the thing that
works so well about the scene it's
agreed but i think there's also this
weird thing with tom cruise where like
if you've watched enough his movies he
feels kind of like a space alien a lot
of the time like he doesn't actually
live in the real world and do real
people things so like tom cruise
understanding how to go on a date tom
cruise throwing a baseball these are
many things you've seen in movies where
you're like i don't think that's really
i don't think you've ever thrown a
baseball have you ever gone on a date
actually before i don't know well i mean
look i haven't been on many dates myself
but i will tell you i'm always trying to
be prim and proper and clean and shower
and all that stuff when i go on a date
however i think that this works
perfectly in the movie and i want to ask
perducy lucy this question too because
tom cruise's maverick is so insanely
confident the guy literally flies a
billion dollar jet for a job and he does
it just about as well as anybody ever
has and so of course he would have that
confidence that i can just show up to
charlie's house and we're gonna hook up
and i don't need to shower i can wear
jeans playing volleyball and i'll be
great at it like this guy has irrational
confidence not just in flying not just
in riding his kawasaki at insane speeds
he believes in this in this version of
himself in every facet of his life so
lucy the question is this how well does
that scene transition from volleyball to
him at charlie's house and the make-out
scene to berlin's take my breath away
how well does that still hold up for for
the fairer sex because i think it works
tremendously
it works tremendously because they're
they're greasing the wheels so to speak
they're getting you ready getting all
the ladies ready with all those hot
greasy men on the on the beach what i
love it's kind of a twist on what
usually happens it's usually the women
are all in their little bikinis greased
up
so
it's nice to get eye candy for the other
sex i think and so i think it's a
perfect transition into when he meets
with charlie
take my breath away it's just and you
see it's like the shadows and you see
like the tongues touch and it's like
that's how you phrase this
it's just there's something so
unrealistic about all of it
um
because if my husband came home from a
greasy like and they had greased
themselves on the volleyball court and
then it was all sandy i'd be like no
that's not happening
but it for some reason it works in this
movie i love it i think it's really
great i've never attempted the top gun
uh level no i have attempted i've never
landed it so to speak so like it like
you know it's it's not tmi been kissing
a girl one time and you go for the top
gun thing and it's like she immediately
pulls you back into her face and is like
no kiss me what you're doing is
attempting to lick and i'm not a i'm not
a tootsie pop we're not seeing how long
it takes me to get to the center it's an
actual kiss and so use your lips more
than the tongue that's just a nice
little psa don't do what the movies
teach you about any of that it's all
fake it's it's just do what feels like
normal and right but don't take any
advice from tom cruise it's weird
thompson improvised that one that's what
the researcher says he's like i'm going
to go in with just my tongue
respond accordingly if you don't have to
pick a favorite character in here is is
it so obvious that it's maverick that i
have to take him off the board or
if you're having a fantasy draft and
you're looking at the board and you have
the number one pick are you all both
taking maverick or is there a wild card
somewhere in there just to touch on your
his like audacious self-confidence the
walking in the ladies room moment for me
like earlier in the movie i'm like
really and we're just okay with it i
mean hey when you got in here you got
crazy maverick
it's just insane confidence but to
answer your question i said it in the
intro i absolutely adore val kilmer and
i think that he did a really good job of
being like incredibly hateable until
he's not because there's the moment
obviously where goose meets his demise
and it feels like as an audience member
you kind of want to be mad at iceman you
kind of want to blame that's why it's
his fault right like and the fact that
it's never brought up past that is
really shocking to me but i think it's
important because i don't think he
becomes redeemable if you see maverick
blame him for the death and then he kind
of just like whether he owns it or
doesn't own it i think it's just like
not a good trajectory for his character
but the fact that i like val kilmer by
the end of this and that you have that
great back and forth them as the last
couple lines of the movie
and then earlier on in the movie he's
just like talking with his teeth a lot
and like biting at people and and
smiling more than you want him to uh
it's all val kilmer for me and then tom
skerritt in a close second but i'm a big
iceman fan ben i i literally have never
had this thought i'm sure a bunch of
articles have been written comparing
these two characters but something about
andrew's talking or maybe it was me not
paying attention to him as i frequently
do on the showdown is
i would say val kilmer is iceman is the
american ivan drago because
same haircut you know same chiseled look
great chin blonde
but at the end killed your best friend
the best friend and so like you you sort
of have a lot of correlation here but by
the end obviously we get that great
moment where they do embrace and and i
wonder if they did have like you come to
jesus talk about hey look it was neither
one of our faults it was just that's
what happens when you're training yeah i
mean i think i think there are some
definite similarities there ellis and i
think that you know some of those some
of those archetypes that we've seen
throughout 80s films there's a reason
they're similar you know that's what
that's what the masses wanted those
movies were only one year apart it's not
surprising those can you guys can you
imagine if we did get the come to jesus
moment between rocky and drago in a
later movie though i mean like obviously
obviously we didn't get that in creed 2
and they cut the scene where those guys
fight in the hospital but i just would
love to see those guys somehow like on
an action mission together at this point
they could still do it they could still
do it well we get the expendables you
know we we get to see them we get to
pretend when i'm watching an expendables
movie and it's sly and it's dolph i'm
just pretending it's rocky and drago and
they patch things up and the government
goes to rocky balboa with his 30 000
concussions and his age 80 and they're
like hey you're the only one for this
mission we're going to pair you with the
transporter guy and you bring a bunch of
your friends and you go get this person
out of this scary situation um
you can't not talk about top gun without
bringing up a couple different things
but the soundtrack is
a legendarily great and top it's one of
the top selling movie soundtracks of all
time it's since been passed by the
bodyguard and by titanic but those might
be that's still the top two you got some
disney ones and i'm sure way up there
but this is a platinum selling album
what's the best cut off of top gun is it
in fact danger zone ben bateman to you
first i'm gonna jump in here first ellis
uh yeah he said you could go first i was
just that excited okay
no no no there's two o's and goose boys
i've got i've
i've got this soundtrack i have the cd
of this soundtrack and i don't even have
a cd player and it's still with me here
in los angeles i brought it with me i
enjoy the soundtrack so very much
obviously the two logins tracks are
incredible i mentioned the lover boy
track heaven in your eyes and you
already called out mighty wings i don't
even know where you start i think
probably over the years
the one that i have found myself singing
the most times is loverboy heaven in
your eyes because it represents all of
those all of those 80s 90s things about
like bolton songs that are just so fun
to sing and especially because i like to
sing so it's a great shower song and
you're very good at it i appreciate that
thank you no i i love that one i i do
think probably if we're gonna go with
one of the more popular tracks
you gotta go playing with the boys
that's like
it's it's i mean it's the volleyball
song it's so good but if i had to pick
just one it would be lovely you said
that three times
you're gonna take all of my songs andrew
i i think he's sticking with loverboy
here which opens the door very wide for
andrew guy to come in here uh i mean i'm
100
going take my breath away whether it's
lucy singing it or on the soundtrack uh
i'm very okay with both of them it's
just incredible i i i like the fact that
that song came from the movie i mean
what could that's almost the best thing
about top gun almost but the story goes
uh lucy that that berlin the band was
approached by the producers and given
the option do they want to tackle danger
zone or take my breath away and they
were hoping that they were going to take
danger zone and so berlin is like oh no
take my breath away that's us that's it
we kiss with just tongues over here all
the time that is what they said they
wanted to do and so then they're like oh
i guess we got to scramble and so then
enter kenny loggins the king of 1980
soundtracks and then you get danger zone
does producey lucy stick with andrew
guy's pick of take my breath away for
the best cut off of the top gun
soundtrack i mean
the the smart part of my brain is like
yeah
but i'm also an archer fan and that's
actually where i first heard when
because archer the character the
animated adult show he's always like
danger zone i
that's the first time i ever heard it
because i saw top gun as an adult
i'm obsessed with danger zone i think
it's the great i didn't know it was a
real song and i didn't understand that
archer loves top gun and wants to be tom
cruise in that movie so when i finally
watched the film and i heard it i was
like wait it's a real song this is
awesome
i love danger zone
it's the best way to kick the movie off
and then we get little hints of it
sprinkled in throughout let's not forget
about i know it wasn't written for the
movie let's not forget about how great
the righteous brothers are closing the
thing out you lost that loving feeling
they sing it a little better i think
bill medley's voice a little bit better
than tom cruise's at least before tom
cruise became stacy jacks but look i i
i'm i'm friends with olio you're missing
the boat here it's simple and the answer
is harold faltermeyer
composing and steve stevens shredding
that guitar for the top gun anthem i
have no idea why people say this is
something of its time this to me is an
all-time great guitar track i still put
it on more often than not if i do
anything that is successful if i
accomplish a task which isn't a lot i
crank out and it's a great song to
finish your run to if you're running and
you listen to your to your pump up music
you close with that sprint to the top
gun anthem it just elevates it a notch i
don't think it's dated i don't think
it's of its time am i wrong here
gentlemen it's not dated you are correct
no it's hi i mean it's amazing the
moment that it starts playing when the
movie starts you're like all right here
we go we're we're ready to go and they
like remind you of it throughout the
movie it's uh it's incredible i agree
it's a great workout song i think my
favorite uh story of any song from this
album is actually that when you were
calling a match early on in the movie
trivia showdown and andrew and i thought
it would be very funny to bring our
mothers to set oh yeah we entered the
match and we had take my breath away as
our entry song and we were playing
characters and you were like great great
entry by these gentlemen who are playing
a song that tom cruise and kelly
mcgillis make love to in the film kind
of strange and
walking out with their moms but all
right it's like one of the funnier
comments you've ever made i remember
watching it back and being like he
totally got us on that one that's pretty
great
if you're at a wedding and they do it
now and now the father and daughter are
going to have their dance and just to
take my breath away you may just want to
slowly back away from that reception and
because you don't know what shenanigans
are going to ensue
from there like i said the soundtrack is
multi-platinum over 10 million units
sold worldwide but it wasn't just the
soundtrack that moved a lot of copies
top gun was the first film
that came out on an affordable vhs
because back in the day kids you see we
used to have these things called
blockbuster and hollywood video and for
me in williamsburg video update and the
actual video cassettes unless you wanted
to tape it on a blank tape off a tv the
video cassettes to buy a movie were like
90 bucks because if they made them
affordable then maybe video stores start
panicking that they're going to be put
out of business top gun came out and
they struck a deal with pepsi so pepsi
agreed that they put a commercial on the
front of topkin so he had to sit through
a 30 second pepsi commercial easy peasy
and then top gun starts and that was the
first affordable vhs and it cost like 27
bucks i think which is a price that i
think we would all happily pay back then
for a vhs copy of top gun and it sold
record numbers ray bans the kawasaki
motorcycle
so much from this movie that we still
have today and now we have a new movie
to get excited about and i want to talk
to y'all about the top gun maverick of
it all how pumped we are for this movie
finally coming out but before we get to
the film that joseph kozinski directs
let's talk about tony scott and i said
he's maybe the greatest action director
i've ever seen what is it about tony
scott that his style lends itself so
well to a movie like this that at times
is supposed to be over the top and as
andrew you would say full throttle tony
scott is a favorite director of mine and
ben's we've talked about all of his
movies at length um
top gun is so interesting because it's
like before a lot of the movies that i
kind of fell in love with tony scott
it's like a retrospective look at it and
when you watch top gun there's so many
tony scott isms throughout it whether
it's the writing on the screen whether
it's the color grading whether it's like
giving it that little blur effect on the
camera or how everyone is so sweaty
always like if you were on a ship in a
tony scott movie you are always covered
in sweat there's so many great things
about this and honestly when you look at
tony scott's films other than maybe like
man on fire a lot of his best movies out
there aren't really that action-packed
they're like set in action scenarios
like unstoppable like taking a pelham
one two three these types of movies and
what i think is really interesting is
like tom cruise when they made this they
didn't want to like glorify violence so
it's like so what is tony scott great at
he's great at like these great character
relations scenes he's great at like
hyping things up and making it cool but
he doesn't have to be like overly
violent in most of his movies so i feel
like there's so many things about this
that line like perfectly up with the
type of movies that tony scott make and
and it's like a precursor to so many
more things that he's going to do in his
career i mean i i absolutely love tony
scott and it's cool to watch him kind of
evolve over the next 30 years of
filmmaking it's an amazing point i don't
think i've ever heard a more studious
answer from you andrew guy that was
incredible are you reading off prompt
that was that was amazing
it's it yes so don't ask me any more
questions because i won't ask you any
follow-ups but but ben as i kind of pin
it over to you for your thoughts on tony
scott as a director
of all his films and particularly top
gun andrew made the point that they
didn't want to glorify violence
necessarily in this movie and they do
tiptoe around it remarkably well because
they couldn't put a lot of violence in
here because the script had to be
approved by the powers that be at the
pentagon there's so many movies officer
and a gentleman is one of them didn't
cut the mustard it was too much romance
and too many shenanigans i guess going
on in that film for the pentagon to
officially give it the stamp of approval
top gun got it and i think that tom
cruise and and the department of justice
were like um or the department of
defense i guess we're like we don't want
too much violence we don't want too much
actual bloodshed in this movie but we
did get an emotional sequence with goose
passing away and and it still hits home
for me so tony scott as a director ben
bateman your thoughts i mean he's uh
he's arguably in my my five or ten
favorites of all time i've realized as
the years have passed how much affection
i have for tony scott and i think
it's interesting we've compared him on
our podcast over the years to michael
bay in a lot of ways because they have
similar elements to their movies but
where they have very similar action
their lighting is similar but it feels
like in a michael bay movie he's got a
big explosion then okay shoehorn in an
emotional scene and it doesn't matter
just transitions the action it's kind of
exactly the opposite with tony scott
movies and you notice that year over
year he gets better and better as his
career goes on
it's like the most important concepts
for him were always
what's the depth of this moment between
these characters i'm gonna make this a
little longer i'm gonna make it a little
melodramatic and i think those are the
things that make his movies so powerful
to me i've realized over the years too
that i used to call them sort of
ridiculous i don't think they're
ridiculous i think they're some of the
most rewatchable movies ever made you
know he made five movies with denzel
washington you mentioned pelham one two
three deja vu crimson tide even the bad
the worst of those five movies which is
probably pelham one two three is super
rewatchable i mean i love kind of almost
every movie that guy ever made i think
he swings for the fences and you hear
stories about him as a director
really just being kind of a wild man and
i think you can you can feel it in some
of his choices sometimes but i think
there's an emotional depth to the scene
you're talking about with you know after
goose's death with with maverick and meg
ryan and it's reflected in almost every
one of his movies you get some scene
like that that really stands out and and
there's an emotional weight to his to
his filmmaking that is the most
endearing quality i think he has tony
scott fired three times from top gun at
different points but uh he's stuck on
got it was like george costanza like he
got fired but he showed up for work the
following monday and they let him keep
his job and we ended up getting the
great top gun another moment that he
directed
in this film that's that's super
emotional watching it especially like
i've seen this movie so many times but
it still gets me is before we lose goose
when it's you know mavis just being a
hot shot and he went below the hard deck
which is you know below the altitude
you're supposed to be at in training and
he ended up getting jester but again he
kind of cheated cause he went below the
hard deck and so there's debate about
whether mavin goose should still be in
top gun and then goose comes over to
mav's place that night and
mav is drinking again and
you know he's like dude every time i go
up there with you it's like you're fine
against the ghost because
you know mavs somewhere is still missing
his daddy duke mitchell who was maybe
the best pilot that ever lived and so it
really gets you it it really still gets
you to this day but the most emotional
impact in this movie is when we lose
goose then we see meg ryan plays his uh
his his young wife in there he's got a
kid my question to you fellas is this
and we haven't seen top gun maverick yet
none of us at some point
does maverick hook up with meg ryan's
character does does mav sleep with
goose's play
you set that up
for such a different question that i
thought you were gonna ask
yeah no i don't i don't think he does
man i think that's probably uh
territory you do not cross that's below
the hard deck if you will i disagree
with you on that one i think there's
gonna be i think there's gonna be a
see a sequence i wouldn't even be
surprised if maverick ends up with her i
don't
sleep with her
but i think
i mean i just think that there's a
grieving process they both love this
person they lost i could easily see you
know matt has to grow up you know he
helps i i don't know i think maybe they
end up together honestly all right well
i'll tell you this if the movie was
directed by michael bay that definitely
happens why because we've already seen
it and it's called pearl harbor so
this is a a fun a fun setup that we
wanted to do as we give our last
thoughts here on top gun before we
transition to mailbag producer lucy had
the idea of giving us a top gun quote
that she wants us each to deliver top
gun is a very quotable movie along with
its rewatch ability those two tend to go
hand in hand so producing lucy you
wanted to hear the line at the end
that is when we're celebrating when we
won the other side in quotes has been
taken down courtesy of mav and isis
heroics and this is when mav and ice
finally embrace with everybody around
them like we just won a championship
that's the line you want these fellas to
read yeah the one where there's the most
sexual tension between iceman and
maverick oh yeah
oh yeah all right so here's how i think
we do it i need i need ben to prompt
andrew so andrew you're going to go
first and then andrew's going to prop
ben so the prompt is obviously you you
two know the line i just want to see
who's a better mav and who's a better
iceman so ben bateman you're ready give
it all you got so i'm saying to him
maverick you can be my wing time you can
be my wingman any time
you nailed maverick you crushed it
maverick says that's uh yeah you guys
are cut all right back to one um ben is
going to be saying the line that
maverick uh th that iceman says to
maverick and then andrew will reply with
maverick's retort all right all right
ready here we go
maverick
you can be my wingman anytime
[ __ ]
you can be mine
that's pretty good strong reading pretty
pretty good and and ben with a very nice
prompt for andrew there that's a good
scene partner all right andrew now it's
not as good of an actor as him so this
is he's gonna he's gonna outdo me on
this all right this is a professional
actor we're dealing with kids
you're still dangerous
but you could be my wingman any time
[ __ ]
you can be mine
oh i don't know who won that lucy
because because
ben went up a notch ben went up in his
register as a trained singer
oprah tom cruise
you know what
i'm gonna cast because i'm gonna have to
cast both of you
i'm going to cast
i'm going to cast ben
as
maverick
andrew
but only because your iceman your iceman
is really good that was amazing then
let's be honest andrew was much happier
being cast as iceman i don't think
there's any question about that oh he's
thrilled about it and i guess that means
that i'm either hollywood or wolf man
because i'm the guy that they have to go
pick up in the ocean to come back
hey guys guys put a couple beers on ice
for me because i got shot down but but
i'll be there in a couple hours don't
worry about me yeah yeah i i love that
and i also love that mav is waiting on
the tarmac because he's pretty much the
backup and he has to go into the game to
hit the game-winning shot and the way
that they radio in that it's like time
for mab to go and take off because
highway wolf man got shut down i do not
know how pilots they have to rely on
their instincts you cannot understand a
word that they that they are saying over
that radio it's just like i remember
highway and it's like i guess that means
go we take off now yeah yeah i mean
that's uh a language that i don't know i
can't understand it at all that's what i
have captions on for
well you both are great at talking film
and this was a uh just uh uh what a nice
walk down memory lane and uh and as we
look forward to top gun maverick i mean
our expectations no pun intended are sky
high about this right fellas ben i know
you you and i were talking i get to see
this movie as of the tape by the time
this episode comes out i will have seen
top gun maverick i am seeing it this
week i'm seeing it on saturday of this
recording so
i am like
it's gonna be you know how you you get a
free refill of large popcorn i'm not
relying on that i'm getting two tubs to
kick off and then i'm going into the
theater ben bateman your expectations
for top gun maverick you know
normally if this was any franchise other
than
one led by tom cruise i would say i'm
extremely skeptical i think sequels that
come this far like this many years later
it's just they usually don't work out
but there's something about this movie
there's something about the involvement
of crews the trailers i've seen what i'm
the buzz i'm hearing i think this movie
is going to be great i like really think
at worst i think this movie is going to
be highly entertaining but i think this
movie might actually just be great
there's so many choices that they made
in this movie that i really love like i
think miles teller as a casting choice
is phenomenal for that role
i even like that you know so often you
see a star like cruz in their mid-50s
and and the female lead they cast in the
movies like 25 or whatever jenna
mcconnell is like 50. i think she's
close to she's within 10 years of cruz's
age it's like feels age appropriate it
doesn't feel like a stretch that's silly
to watch um not silly but just you know
the hollywood thing there's a lot about
this movie that i just really like the
look of and i also like that they waited
for technology to catch up which is one
of the things i in in that bts segment
that they showed where chris was like i
just didn't want to do this until we
could actually make the the jets look
way better like make them look amazing
and i think it's going to be awesome for
that reason yeah it is so it's not going
to be the mummy where it's like he's go
he's dating someone fresh out of college
so if that's uh yeah
good news but i'm just fair warning to
jennifer connolly uh you never know when
meg ryan could show up so um andrew guy
you're in the theater you're about to
see top gun maverick what's going
through your mind you know it's it's
fascinating because we listen to those
uh the reviews at the top of the show
and and i find them that those reviews
haven't really aged well and maybe it's
because like the dog fighting now in
2022 when you watch an 86 film isn't
quite as impressive
we've always said that the best moments
in action movies are the moments in
between the action well with top gun
maverick i think it's going to be a
beautiful blend of both i mean you look
at the behind the scenes stuff that
they're doing the camera work the fact
that they're actually in these jets the
actors are being their own
cinematographers
that action is going to be absolutely
incredible breathtaking but then you
also have the fact that goose's son is
going to be there so you know you're
going to cry i i just honestly my
expectations are through the roof i
think it's going to be really great the
only thing is that you know rest in
peace i wish that tony scott was
directing it but i think since he's
going to do a good job and
i think a lot of the conversations that
tom cruise and tony's got have leading
up to tony scott's tragic passing
we're about top gun too so this does
feel like sort of a nod to tony scott
alongside a movie that we all anticipate
is going to be a gigantic blockbuster in
one of the highest grossing movies of
the summer so uh this was if there was
an episode to have both your fellas
debut on rt is wrong this is the one
thank you all so much for uh uh lending
your talents to this podcast uh where
can everybody find all the stuff you're
working on i'll let you all do it as
individuals so andrew why don't you kick
off i know you got a bunch of projects
in the can uh yeah i got a couple movies
coming out there's one called a bogota
trip the other one's called always lola
so keep your eyes out for those uh and
then ben and i do a podcast every single
week roughly you know we take you know
sometimes it'll be every other week but
it's called the best in the worst where
we take anything in film history whether
it's an actor director or franchise and
we rate the best and the worst of them
we recently did guillermo del toro we're
gonna do michael bay and i know that
we're gonna do tony scott when maverick
comes out so uh yeah check out the best
the worst podcast and yeah thanks so
much for having us man this wasn't this
was an absolute blast
and ben you you just released a bunch of
uh a crop of new songs that sound great
i i did yeah i put my first song out
back in april of 21 and i'm going on
tour this summer those dates are
available on the link tree in my bio so
follow me at ben baitman media
everywhere that i am drew mentioned the
podcast that we do the best and the
worst uh that's kind of my my weekly
hour-long movie talk and i started
posting these little minute long movie
reviews on tick tock recently so check
that out as well it's the same handle
everywhere so at some point i'm getting
into the tick tock i just been resisting
it as long as i can so those are the
action guys that is ben bateman and
andrew guy follow them across all social
media platforms you know what i usually
sign us off here by thanking producey
lucy and our engineer bryan perez and
the whole staff here at rotten tomatoes
and you the listeners for rating
reviewing subscribing all that good
stuff but i think instead let's give ben
bateman another crack at singing like
tom cruise in the bar
to lead us out here ben at your ready
just pretend like kelly mcgillis is
there at the bar andrew's right next to
you he's goose i'm iceman in the corner
just paying attention to my vodka and
nothing else
you never close your eyes anymore when i
kiss your lips
can i do it worse than that maybe a
righteous brother
that's gonna do it for us here at rotten
tomatoes is wrong that's the worst ben
bateman's ever sounded singing he's got
some great yes it is go check it out
thanks for tuning in we'll catch y'all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you